one in seven men suffer from STS on a  daily basis and don't even know it  these are doctors lawyers plumbers and  baristas they walk the streets unaware  of how their choice to wear square-toed  shoes negatively affects their lives  and the people they care about I went on  a date  and I was actually I was actually really  excited about it but he didn't tell me  that he has STS my father wears square  toe shoes I tried to give him hints but  he doesn't get it  I feel so disconnected from him  and I wonder I pass this on to my  children Henry was the perfect candidate  he had a great resume and all the right  references but when he walked into the  room we all noticed his shoes were just  too ugly it's not too late if you or  someone you know has been affected by  STS visit us at Genki comm we're here to  help  square right angles wrong choice  [Music]